[Música]
de la región de borgoña creemos conocer
de memoria el patrimonio sus abadías
luminosas su arte de vivir su
prestigioso viñedo pero esta región
oculta también tesoros de golosinas más
íntimos
[Música]
en el pequeño pueblo de flavini un
extraño perfume flota en el aire desde
hace siglos aquí en estos tanques se
fabrica uno de los bombones más antiguos
de Francia el anís de flavinini para un
anís desde el grano hasta el bombón
final se requieren 15 días dan vueltas
por lo menos una vez al día pero como
agregamos jarabe cada vez para que no
quede mucho sirope encima hay que darle
un poco de tiempo en secado
pero como el anís está especia
mediterránea se abrió camino hasta los
confines de la región de borgoña
quien encabeza la fábrica nos guía hacia
los orígenes del Bombón creado en esta
antigua abadía
los romanos subieron con especias entre
ellas el grano de anís creo que en la
época galorromana y después cuando los
niños vinieron tuvieron la idea de
cubrir el pequeño grano de anís con
sirope de azúcar para hacer con él una
pequeña almendra confitada
desde hace más de 100 años la familia de
Katherine perpetúa esta historia ahora
indisociable del apellido flavini
y de esta pequeña caja oval por aquello
de la preferencia local los jóvenes de
la región se ocupan de la
condicionamiento
trabajamos aquí durante las vacaciones
escolares
porque catering y su padre siempre
privilegiaron a la gente del pueblo
entonces trabajamos aquí durante las
vacaciones y nos quedamos
yo conocí a mis abuelos en aquella época
lo comían mucho
son ellos quienes me dieron ganas de
trabajar aquí hay miembros de mi familia
que trabajaron aquí etcétera etcétera
el más joven tiene un año y ya prueba
los pequeños dulces los más pequeños
aromatizado con Rosa menta O Violeta el
anís de flavini No para de hacer adeptos
su pequeña caja oval se exporta incluso
a Europa Japón y a los Estados Unidos
[Música]
la capital de borgoña también gusta el
anís pero más en el pan de especias en
esta tienda una de las más antiguas de
la ciudad se mantiene la leyenda del
bollo especial una golosina que hace
fundir los paladares de dijon desde la
Edad Media
[Música]
los que están rellenos de mermelada de
naranja terbaricoque frambuesa eso es lo
que prefiero son estos pequeños panes de
especias con forma redonda Generalmente
relleno de mermelada los nietos se
reencuentran con la tienda donde la
abuela les compraba pan de especias
aquí se fabrica pollo especiado desde
hace 225 años
el legado de una familia la de catering
petitlán novena generación que encabeza
la empresa
aquí encontramos a Augusto petición
quien es el dirigente de mulhoy petillón
quien hizo construir el lugar en el que
estamos instalados hoy en día
hace 25 años que su padre Le entregó las
llaves de la casa hace 25 años que su
padre Le entregó las llaves de la casa
lo que me impulsó fue que me tuvo
confianza creo que la confianza de los
padres es importante y me dejó las
riendas de la empresa me dejó decidir
porque yo me preparo para entregarle la
empresa a mi hija una deliciosa
tradición transmitida inicialmente por
monjas que confeccionaron y le dieron el
nombre al bollo especial
Emmanuel los llegód prefiere mantener un
silencio religioso sobre la receta aquí
hay 146 kilos
pero les puede garantizar algo aquí la
fabricación siempre es artesanal
moldeado a mano domado a mano y luego
metido al horno a mano y sacado del
horno a mano hacer la cocción con los
antiguos hornos es estupendo
un orgullo local que reúne más allá de
la región de borgoña Este joven obrero
es de Lyon y trabaja aquí desde hace
tres años el pan de especias es un
Magdalena de post desde pequeño los
bollos especiados los glaseados delgados
adoquines de 6 kilos todo es bueno
en la región nos gusta tanto el pan de
especias que tratamos de combinarlo con
la estrella local la mostaza
entonces hay que dosificar sutilmente
para combinar la mostaza y el pan de
especies
[Música]
la receta no es tan nueva figuraba en
las libretas de un gran artesano
productor de mostaza de borgoña edmon
filo un siglo más tarde su nieto la
revivió
que la inclusión tiene un color como
ambarino
son dos ingredientes que se armonizan
muy bien
o como reinventar su patrimonio
gastronómico perpetuando sus tradiciones
la región de borgoña no está lista para
perder su sabor
[Música]